[Musique]
imaginez imogène imaginez que vous êtes
un enfant et que vous avez une bulle de
savon à la place de coeur imaginez
qu'une émotion trop vive
un effort de trop puisse faire tout
éclater ce coeur qui n'a pas même un
lendemain à vivre c'est le mien je suis
né avec une maladie cardio pulmonaire le
pronostic vital établi par les médecins
et d'une petite dizaine d'années sur
terre mes parents s'en remettre aux
dieux médecins aux chiffres des écrans
bleus qui font écran à tout espoir
je suis orpheline de parents vivant gère
dans le couloir de l'hôpital
kom al-hitan enfants abandonnés
août
un petit loupé excusez-nous mon seul
compagnon
et mon petit crayon à papier une feuille
sur la table at on entame on lit
d'hôpital et voici la porte de tout mais
échappée dessinée illuminé suspens la
course de temps un peu comme la petite
marchande d'allumettes
j'allume des dessins pour me réchauffer
lorsqu'il m'arrive de maudire ma
situation
la maladie dial up alors je gomme
sagement les statistiques je plante des
dessins et j'attends qu'il pousse
finalement je grandis et des passes des
pronostics ce qui permet aux médecins de
me proposer une transplantation
j'ai 14 ans je suis inscrite sur les
stades attente de greffe coeur-poumon je
dois me tenir prêtes pour qu'à n'importe
quel moment
l'équipe vienne me chercher pour tenter
cette opération je vis la tente dans une
extrême solitude qui est le creuset de
forces insoupçonnées comme il y a plus
eu plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
meurent chaque année par manque de
donneurs les prothèses de prendre trois
organes qui peuvent sauver 3 vies et non
une seule la mienne me désespère
finalement entre tourments et
acceptation je consens à ce que me
donnera la vie et je laisse les
mâchoires du temps pulvérisez mon
effroyable inquiète une mort been qui
aggravent tout ennemi la vie en moi
alors je préfère donner raison à la vie
de m'avoir créer comme ça et je m'en
remets aux grands summer de d'estimé
contre toute attente je deviens
finalement adolescente ma poitrine ses
desserts je quitte ma bouteille
d'oxygène
je m'envole hors du cac vous dans
l'université ardente de mon être je suis
infectées par le virus de la liberté je
ne suis pas née vivante je le deviens je
poursuis ma soif de vivre en mes
entrailles jeux vidés mais j'ai vu des
larmes
mes passions amoureuses temps
désespérément de combler les manques de
l'enfance où j'ai reçu des piqûres et
des coups de scalpel plutôt que de la
tendresse tragique impasse illusoire je
me rate impérialement je cherche à
l'extérieur de moi même donc je m'occupe
et l'homme avec qui je tente une vie de
couple me trahis
c'est le reflet de mon intériorité
comment puis-je munir à l'autre si je
suis désuni un terme
je mesure combien je suis loin de
l'amour inconditionnel que j'exige
pourtant le démon de la jalousie celui
de l' amour possessif à pleins pouvoirs
je suis submergé par la pression
extérieure et barrages craque je suis
comme noyé dans l'air en proie à des
hémorragies cataclysmique
la vie me fend le coeur
l'aggravation brutale de la pathologie
me conduit immédiatement à l'hôpital et
je dois attendre jusqu'à la fin
quelle fin la mort ou la vie jusque dans
la mort je suis dans le chaque battement
suffit sa peine
je ressens une écologie intérieur est
indispensable pour mon fragile équilibre
je suis funambule 1 entre vie et mort en
fait dans ma cellule d'hôpital
je rends dans un profond silence et je
ressens que quelque chose ça tarde
auprès de moi quelque chose qui est là
depuis toujours et qui n'attendaient
qu'une seule chose que je lui ouvre la
chambre nuptiale le moqueur gérer un
mariage intérieur où la solitude est
pleine
je ressens combien l'amour et communion
et non de consommation consumation je ne
suis plus aux commandes de moi même
c'est le mois sont mois à la dérive de
tout le connu je me perds et c'est au
moment le plus faible que je livre
passages à plus forte que moi
allongé dans mon lit d'hôpital
je peins cette femme qui m'est apparu
dans un songe
elle a des ailes et portant sa poitrine
un enfant certines en poissons et des
oiseaux
je ressens l'air d'une profonde mutation
la vitre est brisée et l'horizon jailli
dans le bocal de mon asphyxie une
infirmière très pas ma porte et
m'explique que les médecins ont les
organes prévus pour ma greffe
ils sont en train de préparer le bloc
opératoire
de l'autre côté de mon espace temps une
famille endeuillée au coeur de
l'inconsolable chagrin suite à une mort
accidentelle sur la route prend la
décision que oui l'amour est plus fort
que la mort et ce jour là il donne
l'accord pour le prélèvement d'organes
une personne deux trois quatre cinq six
sept huit personnes sont greffés ce jour
là dont moi je m'allonge sur la table
d'opération
je consens à tout perdre
j'ouvre une porte dans un mur
infranchissable qui me mènera peut-être
jusqu'aux étoiles
enfin en tout cas ce que je ressens
c'est que je vis vous que je meurs je
suis vivante
donc je suis prête à me mesurer à ce qui
me mesure jacques 8 ou d'un oui atomique
a pris 20 en attente 20 ans de sursis
je suis miraculeusement opéré le jour du
plus grand rassemblement de prières
faites dans le monde
le jour de notre dame de lourdes le 11
février
j'ai 34 ans les hommes aux mains d'or le
trio de chirurgie armand d'or dans un
flocon de neige l'hiver 2012
un vieux monde s'écroule pour laisser
place à une nouvelle aventure
je suis descendu dans ma chair pour
monter sur la croix de la maladie
aboutissant à une transplantation
coeur-poumon 40 jours en réanimation
quarante jours de traversée sans les
rame à contre courant au plus noir de la
bim dans ce voyage dans ces grandes
profondeurs j'étais en même temps
complètement relié à tout ce qui
m'entoure et une aide soignante pose sa
main sur les miennes mes yeux pourtant
plongé dans un profond coma voit sa
belle couleur de noir et je l'entends
elle chante reprends ton bâton père il
revient non tenables et restent les plus
sombres lorsque les combats où la mort
est préférable à la vie ce qui me tenait
dans mon coma l'équipe médicale me
dépose sur les oreilles la musique de
bach et ce grand architecte de la
musique au nombre d'or me remet ayant
envie je suis livré à de grands face à
face avec mes adversaires
toutes mes peurs tout mais fuite
toutes mes lâchetés tous les endroits où
je ne savais pas délivré l'amour qui
m'habitait tous sont là dragon serpent
léviathan avec leurs grosses mâchoire
bien décidé à ouvrir ce que je n'arrive
pas à ouvrir à l'amour il qu'on casse la
gang qui enferme mon coeur ils
n'attendent qu'une chose que je leur dis
vers cet amour qui ne m'appartient pas
comme par exemple ma mère
dans son costume de dragons alors je
prie pour laisser passer cette fort de
transmutation qui déferle comme l'océan
sur le rocher
ces monstres en fait me révèle une
mémoire secrète qui tout à coup me fais
mes souvenirs je reçois la connaissances
transmises par aucun libre
dans un état de mort clinique
je vis l'extase d'une expérience nue
mineuse et vidés par la foudre foudroyé
d'amour total depuis cette mouture
divine je réalise que rien ne permet
tait la vie l'amour la liberté parce que
je suis l'amour je suis la liberté je
suis la vie en ces fines en braille
métamorphose seul meurt la peur
l'épreuve ne nous est pas donné pour
nous aplatir
elle nous est donnée pour accomplir
notre puissance d'amour dont en effet à
l'image et à la ressemblance
quand je reste en proie mon inconscience
quand je reste petit jeu ne sert pas à
ce monde comme dit notre cher nelson
mandela il verrait lui aussi dans la
synchronicité du jour de notre dame de
lourdes
le 11 février nous sommes et pour rendre
manifeste l'amour inconditionnel qui est
en chacun de nous lorsque nous laissons
notre lumière brille et nous donnons
incidemment aux autres la permission
d'en faire autant lorsque nous nous
libérons de notre propre peur notre
présence libère automatiquement les
autres tous se dévoile amoureusement et
le ténébreux et lumineux
il est mort en moi le jeu de mes frères
j'ai béni mes parents qui ont eu ce rôle
d'adversaires ils ne m'ont pas retenu
j'ai pu tenter cette traversée j'ai pu
me risquer et me perdre pour trouver mon
véritable nom de vie je bénis l'homme
qui m'a trahi la crise aline de l'amour
conditionné est brisé je bénis la main
qui me persécutent
sans elle je ne peux mourir à tout ce
qui me tue sans elle je ne peux déployés
mais elle en vérité
lorsque nous calomnier que nous
piétinons le coeur de quelqu'un ou que
nous déversons notre vision fataliste
d'esclaves résigné nous nous piétinons
et lorsque tu te lèves tu élèves le
monde
je me souviens de mon futur je me
souviens de cette splendeur que nous
sommes tous alors je réécris mon passé
il est devenu imprévisible
je leur ai écrit à la lumière du présent
ma mémoire respire je viens retournement
total dans un dérèglement insensé de
tous mes sens le bocal est renversée et
tous se déverse dans lors du dérisoire
mais images tailler mes certitudes
mes croyances mes illusions mais
sécurité illusoire s'effondre rien ne
tient debout
le mystère le plus grand pour moi eco
comble notre impuissance
nous voici un vulnérables rien qui ne
soit plus soumis aux proies de la
destruction
tu la dégénérescence que le corps et
pourtant la porte de notre éternité cet
engagement a pleine confiance et ma plus
belle façon d'incorporer mon sauveur je
suis son écrin où la mort est morte et
la vie ressuscitant mois
[Applaudissements]
cher frédéric le marchand données sans
hésiter votre coeur à tout ce qui est
beau ainsi il battra éternellement
langues de feu que christian bobin
m'envoie lorsque je suis revenu de ce
long voyage où j'ai appris que je suis
qui je suis et maintenant je tente de le
devenir
je vois à des joies de partager des
choses avec vous ou plutôt de partager
le miracle des choses des choses qui ne
sont pas des choses c'est notre rendez
vous d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]